greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by Fuji sports.com listen for your
gaze your match your shin guard your
mouthpieces your [ __ ] Muay Thai
gloves there's only one stop and that's
[ __ ] Fuji sports calm all my G's of
Fuji
that's all I [ __ ] live in Fuji I'm a
fat [ __ ] what happens is I get me a god
your target target tongue on my neck I'm
about to commit suicide like I'm Anthony
Bourdain but you never you get me cuz I
got a Fuji it's tougher you can hang it
on my [ __ ] knee like your [ __ ]
gorilla and you own rip that
[ __ ] that's why I only run with
Fuji Sports so do yourself a favor
you're looking for a gay a fat man gay a
five a six Fuji Sports is your answer
for to go to Fuji Sports calm right now
in press in charge BAM and get 10% off
delivered right to your [ __ ]
crib that's how we do and help out the
podcast number two and it's got a new
thing it's called on at six it's a six
weeks transformative transformational
exercise program you're going on it
you'll login
I think it's $49 for six weeks you
workout with Aubrey I think one of his
buddies for an hour every day in the
privacy of your own home [ __ ]
phenomenal give it a shot like I'm
saying if it's either that or the
supplements that's always there for you
whether it's alpha brains of a shroom
tech or the [ __ ] protein powders
whatever you need
they got you covered go to on at that
time right now on press in church ban
and get 10% off a little bit to your
[ __ ] crib let me tell you
something the future is heated
I've been telling you [ __ ] for
years the futures here they got here you
people that want rollerskates and fly in
the air that's great
you know I got I got breeze I got
breezed thousand milligram breath mints
listen to this listen listen
that's a breath spray right there
[ __ ]
ten [ __ ] shots a [ __ ] spray that's
the future he understand me when you go
to your little weed store tell them on
well Joey says I want the breeze spray
where the [ __ ] is debris spray and the
breeze mints that's what you need
kick this [ __ ] mealy it's Monday
morning that's [ __ ] Sammy Hagar hey
there's a this is Sammy Hagar with
Ronnie Montrose like 19 [ __ ] 70
something eglee can you play make
love by kiss just 15 seconds 15 seconds
it sounds just like this watchmaking
love kiss I don't know which one came
out first but basically we're opening up
[ __ ] Father's Day strong this is
tremendous and double platinum yeah I
don't know what year that came up that
year Ronnie Montrose who the [ __ ] knows
the school he's great Space Station what
year did that Space Station number 5
because making love came out in 76 77
yeah so maybe Montrose lifted it it's a
very basic roof there's a there's
actually 5 million songs like that I
guess ya know there's another song that
sounds like Michael Shanklin there's
another song by rushed it sounds a
little like this it's weed if you black
out by scorpions it's similar to that
too yeah they'd be getting a black guy
alright is such a [ __ ] Hughes out if
people remember that song crushed me
yeah I don't actually didn't want to
like scorpions because when you're a kid
you kind of attach yourself to a band
like a like a football team like that
the album that you bought like a by bata
key I bought a kiss record none of my
other friends are gonna buy kiss records
they're just gonna borrow mine and tape
it right and then if my buddy buys rush
I'm not gonna buy rush now that's his
band I'm gonna tape that [ __ ] right
but whoever owns the master like the
album that's like they're bad you know
what I mean so I didn't want to like
scorpions because Eric bought scorpions
I had he bought the scorpions first so I
was gonna [ __ ] with scorpions just
borrow [ __ ] when I borrow blackout and I
put [ __ ] this all black out on [ __ ]
that that song destroyed me I play it on
my stepdads Fisher stereo and he was in
work I wasn't allowed to play my records
on his stereo but when he's at work I'd
because he had I'm two speakers I had
one speaker in my room I didn't even
know what stereo was so I thought I
would listen to kiss records but only
hear one guitar I didn't understand
stare I didn't know that was more music
coming out of the other speaker so when
I play my kiss records on my dad stare
my stepdads stare when he was at work I
said what the [ __ ] there's new parts in
this [ __ ] I heard like other guitar
parts what the [ __ ] is going on he's got
like a magical stereo didn't get it I
was like 7 anyways
tremendous tremendous I love all this
but blackout [ __ ] me up
black hours the song ran I was like [ __ ]
I don't really want to wiping that
scorpions that much but [ __ ] you can't
dinner good songs about that's it yeah
on the other side they got one of my
favorite songs they've ever done that
was an ax wrestler strippers danced to
it a lot it's just one of those Jenna
scorpions are a weird band because I got
into him I got it like what my favorite
scorpy that was his animal magnetism mmm
the chicks about to blow the dog or
something like that she's not even now
next to a [ __ ] Doberman Pinscher
something like that they had a couple of
good shots they had a lot of good songs
but I was trying to resist him I mean I
didn't like the guys vocals I didn't
like the music I'm not crazy about it I
didn't like the fact that you can hear
his accent in the music you know what I
mean I for some reason as a kid it was
hard for me to accept like you can tell
like you know live you would go you know
he'd sounded like he was Asian you know
is it was not that Hitler concept was
yeah and it was four foot aid in yeah he
had he didn't have good hair I just
judged too much on appearance you had a
guitar players were [ __ ] phenomenal
all of chancre we loved shank a Michael
and there's a funny video I'm [ __ ]
Michael just torturing ruler then he
covered the band he carried the band
he's a [ __ ] bum tremendous [ __ ] thank
you for coming to Disneyland
that was awesome that is surreal because
I wanted we were gonna go to Lego at
first and my wife called me back she
goes bro it's two hours she don't puke
18 times yeah well we just pull the
[ __ ] trigger and go to Disneyland and
I was like let's do it so look up you
know what happened when she came back
she goes only
tell you well let's go and my wife
called your wife and I'm happy that the
kids have a great time
well the thing that was special about
this is uh we don't have to wait any
goddamn lines man you got that you got
that Jennifer Lopez I can't go back to
Disneyland any other way now you can't
do it I got you said I got spoiler good
seeing able having a guide walk into any
ride you want cuz that Fast Pass [ __ ]
that [ __ ] don't work cuz you buy Fast
Pass and you check the app and like
nothing's available that's some [ __ ]
that's a ripoff and well I don't want to
say a ripoff I don't want to say
[ __ ] I'm just it's not what I
expected I take that back I don't want
to get sued the [ __ ] happened the other
day I haven't talked about it we get up
you know whatever we all meet at 9:00
we're gonna get the tour guides or
whatever I think we got high right here
we get high upstairs no I didn't know
Hannibal in my pocket I had a [ __ ]
tushy a t-shirt TKO edible in my pocket
and I'm like it's Disney where what what
you know what's the big [ __ ] deal
so as I walk in they got metal detectors
and me being the [ __ ] that I am I
took that tushy out of my pocket are now
another ten I leave that [ __ ] in my
pocket yeah it's not gonna ring it if it
does ring oh well then you go all which
this investment or whatever they look at
it they let you go yeah I took it out on
my back in this chicks like oh you can't
go home with that you have to bring that
back to your room they okay no problem I
the honey and you're right there and
Drake that was right to have my wife my
daughter right there they go
when they go back to the room and put
this not my idea was it I wasn't gonna
go back to the robots and I go to the
hallway in the hotel either piece and
come back and that's exactly what I did
I went to the hallway and I hate a piece
and I truly had a piece away I hate a
hundred milligrams it's all I needed I
didn't want [ __ ] a ton of anxiety in
this point I just wanted something to
get me in the park
get me wigglin you know just to get me
wiggling I [ __ ] either I walk back up
I go up to the girl and she goes we had
somebody follow you if you didn't go oh
my god
yeah it was the creepiest thing ever
that you want to piss me off you want to
piss me off
pull some police [ __ ] on me or [ __ ]
uh question me
well [ __ ] tell me what to do like
that [ __ ] drives me crazy all that [ __ ]
drives me crazy and when you pull that
police that how much of police [ __ ] on
me
that really pisses me the [ __ ] off you
you really want to piss me off
pull that amateur [ __ ] out me like so
she's nuts telling me that I didn't
throw it away and I might listen I threw
it away like a listen let's cut this
[ __ ] if you don't want me in here since
you threw him on cuz I got pissed I know
since you put [ __ ] the inspector on
me let's go
we spent a lot of money for this we
don't need this [ __ ] I'm cancelling
right now and she's like why I didn't
say that I don't know that's what you
say I go number two I do you know what
between you and I you don't get paid
enough you don't get paid enough to give
a [ __ ] about this [ __ ] this is an easy
job that you're just creating it for
yourself and I would never say that to
somebody but I'm sick and [ __ ] tired
I'm 55 I hate that [ __ ] amateur cop
[ __ ] I always have you're an amateur cop
they're giving you eight bucks and that
ought to be a security guard that's what
you are take it for granted you're not
gonna stop no criminals you getting a
boxer now why are you getting so he over
about this [ __ ] job you know I'm
saying like you know you watch the town
when they're gonna rob that bank and Ben
Affleck you tell him I don't like that
guy he leave buckles his boots up do I
he's a [ __ ] security guard he's
getting six bucks now baby thinks he's
[ __ ] Rambo there's those guys out
there I know people who do that job will
tell you robbed me I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm not pulling out my gun for 18 bucks
on that dog I'm not born that I know
[ __ ] that I've come to me over
the years and go dog I'm guarding a
million bucks on the Tuesday night
[ __ ] 16 now come hit me in there with
a stick and take that money with tanga
rubbish but if you really [ __ ]
believe that they give a [ __ ] about you
and they really don't give a [ __ ] about
you I mean that night I went home and on
TV there was a thing about Disney
they're not even getting 15 bucks an
hour so this chick is busting my [ __ ]
balls about an edible it's not a park
who gets a free time saying like what is
wrong with [ __ ] people and you're
Mattel what really pissed me
that I'd love to call her a white [ __ ]
but she was Mexican that should really
piss me off
she was Mexican trying to act like
[ __ ] Mildred knock it off you're not
[ __ ] what those cops on TV when we
were kids on CBS the to wash ships no
that's the [ __ ] guy on the motorcycle
that [ __ ] pisses me off I'm going
I regard Lister that the security guard
came out thinking we're gonna call our
boss the boss came out and the boss
asked what happened I got a fucked-up me
and I brought that with me she told me I
don't need somebody following me back
the lady goes her name is Mark to
something and the guy's name is whatever
you want to press formal charges but I
don't know I just want to [ __ ] be
left alone and she put out her hand you
saw me like she came when I left
wow that was how fast that what we did
what let me tell you something I'm not
gonna argue with that little chubby
mexican chick mhm because the potato
those [ __ ] edibles are not good on a
ride oh my god oh I got a lot of
videotape oh I know you do a beautifies
closed on all of them people were
telling me you should make that a show
go to all these men these men parks like
Kirk Bert Kreischer used to do and just
videotape Joey on rollercoasters they
show you have to make them wait it's
fine when you smoke weed and get on a
roller coaster it's one thing we didn't
end up with yellow roller so you said
thinking about all the [ __ ] roller
coaster acts every time you hit and you
go up you're like I'm flying off this
[ __ ] building that's what I'm scared
about like went down storm went down the
last one what was it the heavy-duty one
at the end when you it's all black and
[ __ ]
Oh a spaceman spaceman spaceman I was
worried about my daughter if she falls
out of that thing you'll never see her
again
it's the [ __ ] that's why it's black you
let me people fall in love it's only
people got to the bottom with my kid
pool or something get them and they hold
them and they whisk you away in a car
and your kids never seen again that's
where they [ __ ] take your kids and
Disneyland
that's you gotta watch your [ __ ] kids
that's who steals your kids that's a
perfect place to be a [ __ ] pedophile
in Disneyland the white van pulls up
Disneyworld just got busted for what
they arrested some employees that we're
up to no good you didn't hear about that
all over the internet I don't know the
details though no I mean I don't give a
[ __ ]
see that's why when I go to those places
you gotta definitely watch to get but
the whole thing I got out of this
Thursday that was funny was Danny were
[ __ ] badge I heard you and you were a
single guy and you know me when I was a
single guy yeah and now we're like these
[ __ ] that did you ever think this day
was gonna happen
never never did you think you will enjoy
it as much as you do I didn't I was
actually scared that I'd be like my
father I thought what if it's hereditary
what if I have a kid I don't give a [ __ ]
I was really worried about that
and then um I got a bunny nice I [ __ ]
fell in love with this bunny man and I
treated it like it was my son it's crazy
and when it died [ __ ] crushed me it
crushed me
do you remember good time do you ever
watch good times your TV show the good
yeah yeah like after like three or four
seasons they had to kill the father off
John Amos killed the mom and it was the
season finale when Florida was on the
phone and and she gets the call that
he's dead and this out of the season and
she goes that's exactly how what I did
when my wife called me to tell me the
bunny who died I was on the phone I was
like screaming that was screaming there
and at that point I thought you know
what I I need to have kids I'm 40 it's
time to do this you know what I mean I'm
it's getting too late I partied enough I
went out I was single for you know ten
years straight I got that out I don't
miss that at all
you know I mean if you have a kid in
your early 20s it's gonna be in your
head that followed maybe I did this too
soon and [ __ ] I could be out partying
losing my life and all that [ __ ] when
you have a kid when you're 42
that shit's gone like I'm I don't miss
that [ __ ] at all I've done it all I
don't need it I know I know what it's
like you don't miss ufc's
if I never never went to UFC it's crazy
I wouldn't give a [ __ ] I've been so mad
it's so common some guy came up to me at
the airport a what is your next UFC I go
bro I love having out I'd rather watch
that [ __ ] ain't my bed on my phone I
can't go ahead half the time to even go
any man like I don't go this was the
time I go nice it shows up his [ __ ]
[ __ ] the USC I don't need that
[ __ ] though [ __ ] that I made my mind up
a long time yeah yes he gets UFC it gets
naughty we I mean like Joe I mean he's
like John Lennon [ __ ] he's got Hyde from
every other way these stops to take one
picture there's gonna be swarm that's
gonna he's gonna be caught up for an
hour not taking pictures you know cuz
Joe doesn't like to turn down pictures
and you know it's um it's it's crazy you
gotta hide there but it is it's a
[ __ ] that case I don't know how he
does it I've been to every single UFC
between 2003 and 2010 that was my my
stent
I've been I I've had enough it's the
greatest show ever invented
I still watch them but I don't give a
[ __ ] about going to see it live anymore
unless I'm cornering like Tony or
something then then it's fun but I'd
rather watch it on my phone
we're not doing the seventh by the way
I'm doing the Icehouse okay I was just
funny watching you it was funny like it
for a while I was high I was sitting
next to young rides called Jesus Christ
who would I saw this coming like I I
love being a dad Eddie I could have been
a dad a toilet I told her what to calm
me down I thought it would give me a
purpose you know yeah I ended up having
that kid when I was [ __ ] 27 and now I
don't talk to that child at all so I
felt really guilty when I knocked up
Terry cos I like you I go what if this
doesn't work out yeah I'm gonna have two
kids out there in the real world and I'm
not a bad dad I know I know that this is
not this is not what I wanted with
Jackie but this is the way the cards
play there's nothing
you could do about this the way the hand
played out I gave up a life to get a
life you don't saying like I'm at peace
with it now because I left there but I
got something I became a comedian I
became a human being I pay my taxes I go
to bed early I don't do drugs anymore I
became a human being so I made some of
my life I didn't do it to end up in jail
like they thought I would do them saying
so now I have that regret but at the
same time I'm doing the best I go with
mercy yeah you know and it shows it
reflects the house is happy I didn't
grow up with a happy house there did you
hello wait I go I could see it unhappy
house from a mile away
you know I'm saying my house is very
happy now but I had to work hard to make
that house get happy like you have to
work hard at it yeah you have to you
have a degree of so much input like all
this stuff you know when I was little I
loved going on the road I love doing
comedy but guess where I love my family
more absolutely absolutely I understand
the need to make a living and that's
what I basically do I make a living I
don't try to kill myself and you drive a
Mercedes Benz and get a [ __ ] rocket I
get a two million dollar house I don't
need that that's just too much that
would be stress on me and say I was
telling you guys earlier I finally
realized what happened with the Netflix
thing in Vegas I started carrying Eddie
I've always never [ __ ] given a [ __ ]
horse and now I give a [ __ ] about the
audience
you can't give a [ __ ] you have to do
what you do and let the audience jump on
your channel you know that you can't
change what you do because the audience
so I went into it thinking a little
differently and now from now on sadly I
thought about that one on stage in
Sacramento we came to the collusive
casino thank you very much we have a
great time I want to thank my man Sergio
for coming out a bunch of people came
out from the podcast but it was one of
my best sets the last two months because
I didn't give a [ __ ] I have two hours of
material do you know I couldn't do 25
for Netflix two weeks ago 25 I thought
it was like [ __ ] pulling teeth hmm
pulling teeth I couldn't do [ __ ]
I got two hours of material yeah
now how crazy is that way
Poland teeth couldn't come up with 25
one side I did it was 26 minutes 27
years in comedy I couldn't come up with
20 or 30 minutes of material someone
asked me recently in an interview if I
could change anything in my life
what would I do and I wouldn't change a
[ __ ] thing because if anything would
would have been altered I may have not
had my son and I can't even imagine that
so I don't have any regrets I did a lot
of [ __ ] up [ __ ] growing up and made a
lot of poor decisions but they all led
to my son and I wouldn't change anything
listen in this life all we have to do is
a couple things right if you really
think about it you have like five big
decisions to make everything else they
could be [ __ ] slippery decisions but
those five main ones you gotta be on
point for that's it that's it it's five
decisions getting into comedy let's not
cope anymore
yeah look at us after all the crazy yeah
how we're brought up and all the crazy
[ __ ] we're at Disneyland with our wives
and our children acting like some white
people exactly - I was - yeah white
children it's it's [ __ ] surreal what
I'm living right now what I'm saying
like you know one minute you're at home
you got a family in the next minute you
see like [ __ ] Kim Kardashian at the
white house it's so [ __ ] surreal like
everything around this anymore you know
you have to take but I take what's at
the house I take what I could control
but I try to control and that's it I'm
good with that [ __ ] don't say like I'm
really good with that everything else
it's gonna happen you can't control that
[ __ ] you don't know that that 29 or 30
you finally realized that at 45 46 can't
control everything
you control a couple of things you
control when you pee when you [ __ ] yeah
you know when you go to the bank you
control a couple things if you get it
like this Iran Latino
Oh Joe can't believing else it's so
[ __ ] great
I'm not the smartest person alive right
now but man at 30 thinking about
thinking about where I was at mentally I
was dumb as [ __ ]
no [ __ ] anything I was so off on so
much so much man I was um I was
brainwashed by MTV man and now looking
I'm just realizing this over the last
couple of years like holy [ __ ] I was
completely programmed by MTV and and
music you know I I was chasing the
mansion with all the girls and the
Ferraris and all that [ __ ] my whole life
I was chasing that I thought okay I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna do it you gotta
have motive motivation enthusiasm you
got to keep going you got to have good
workout that you got to keep working on
a move to Hollywood make the music be
around all the record labels gonna get
signed gonna blow up gonna sell out
arenas it's gonna you know that was I
hundred percent believe that was gonna
happen you know my most of my life and
now you're looking back at my [ __ ] you
you know me I'm I'm a crazy [ __ ]
I believe everything is a conspiracy
there I believe everything is a
conspiracy
and so I'm crazy so I'm you know what I
think now is like I used to think that
you know what the PMRC remember the PMRC
there they're like a group of old white
ladies and are trying to suppress music
and try to put warning labels on albums
I used to think as a kid that the white
people the elite at the very top wanted
to keep us from doing bad things
wanted to keep us from exploiting our
vices I really thought that were and you
know I'm a kid like [ __ ] I'll listen to
any music I want I'll listen to Slayer
Metallica they're trying to tell me not
to listen to it you know this is
[ __ ] don't worry about you know what
we listen to why you're so concerned
with it I really thought that that was
the plan that we're trying to keep us
good and trying to keep the family tight
but now as crazy as I am
I totally I think it's the opposite I
think they're pretending that we're
trying to keep a tight family unit
I think now they're doing everything
they can all these operations going on
to break to divide us break up the
family in any way possible and and as
many ways as possible I think at the
very at the highest level when there
when you look at privatize prisons you
look at hip-hop and then you look at
privatized prisons even like metal look
what they're doing to the kids they're
making the kids really look up to people
promoting violence and remember I'm a
kid I'm growing up I'm uh I hated the
PMRC I hated the the labels but it was
to me as a trick they're pretending they
care just like think about this they
were pretending that were fighting the
war on drugs right they were pretending
they were bringing the drugs in they
were bringing the drugs in and they're
all like dare to keep kids off drugs a
war on drugs all this money came in tax
money to fight the war on drugs they're
bringing it in they're bringing it in
and there's a now their war on terrorism
there's others there's a [ __ ] war on
terrorism they're funding it and
creating it [ __ ] same thing with music
it looks like they're trying to fight it
and hide it you know or or keep it at
bay mm-hmm they like that [ __ ] they want
fucked-up families they're trying to
split up the families they want that
[ __ ] they want they want us corruptible
but they want to be able to corrupt us
everyone that you know they can corrupt
anybody they could blackmail anybody
they like that [ __ ] that's how crazy I
am but they want us to listen to this
[ __ ] house music they want that [ __ ]
they never try to stop Slayer Slayer was
I was a huge third time they weren't
trying to stop Slayer ever and I
wondered they were trying to stop accuse
on 20/20 they had a show trying to stop
Satanism in music and they had like
Twisted Sister and Mike Judas Priest and
all these bands that I'm 15 thinking you
guys got your way off how come you're
not going after King Diamond how can I
go in after creator and destruction and
Slayer those guys are literally talking
about Satan killer babies and draggin
their souls to hell that's what their
albums are about everything how they're
not trying to hide that [ __ ] how come
you're not going after them they never
nobody ever will touch them they were
going after like strongmen
a Twisted Sister come on those guys have
nothing to do with Satan
but anyway so at 15 that's why I started
to distrust like that was ABC 20/20 and
they got it all wrong who's doing the
research I'm 15 go away man you guys
have it all wrong so at that point I
began to distrust what the hell was
going on in the media so I'm now like
again I'm a crazy [ __ ] man I
believe in the craziest [ __ ] I believe
that I believe trends in all of them not
just hip hip hop is the most obvious one
that's the most obvious you look at hip
hop today Takashi's six nine you look at
that [ __ ] what they're promoting they're
promoting they want that he's always in
his Instagram he always has stacks of
cash and he's always like making it rain
in every Instagram video he's just
throwing cash around talking all sorts
of [ __ ] the baddest cars talking [ __ ]
aren't Leona's watches like that's the
biggest thing going around right now and
they're pushing the [ __ ] out of that
then stopping that danced I felt like
the music's that goodies he's I won but
they're pushing the washes [ __ ] I won't
even watch that [ __ ] of your pavement
yeah it's fascinating I wouldn't even
know it's not fascinating to me it is
[ __ ] you gotta be crazy to watch that
[ __ ] especially after you said it that
you were young and that's what you
thought I was the same I'm not watching
it online I'm watching it and disgust
when I was 20 I wanted to be Pablo
Escobar there was no way I was a today
job I wasn't getting no Hartman danger
my plan was to get somebody to rob him
to get 200,000 cash you were influenced
by the media in the car fare no no no I
was influenced by my childhood there was
no scarf by the time Scarface came I was
already robbing [ __ ] so get that
together I was 83 no but no no no I was
never influenced by nothing like that I
was influenced by my childhood the
people I was around when I was a child
hood their Aerosmith did heroin right
yeah yeah and and what year was a first
album uh 69 70 71 how old are you and 69
I was
okay I didn't even know about her you
may have been influenced by no no no we
were talking about this dear Dan in like
white music I didn't start listening to
white music would you look what would
you listen to black music Spanish music
okay then like rock music when I was
going to Catholic school [ __ ] rock music
was not on my agenda that was no no
Black Sabbath nothing like that how was
this in the top 40 don't John do you
remember your first taste of the harder
stuff yeah yeah yeah what Zeppelin to
someone pull that pulled it out at a
frat party somebody plaids up one to
really know then I got high and listened
to it then I got so you thought it was
kind of interesting the first time I
thought it was interesting and then you
got a Zeppelin was interesting Ted
Nugent was interesting free for all that
I'm free for was interesting Aerosmith
rocks was very interesting to me I was
still a little off but once you start
smoking weed once I started smoking weed
at 12 or 13 I would find the time to get
high and listen to those out at this
point 13 14 and 12 yeah 15 15 and I was
into the Eagles Ted Zeppelin heavy you
know were blossoming I was blossoming
but by that time already the criminality
in my life I'd started blossoming early
because it was nothing
it was nothing you know I was telling
somebody that well they've done given
that Terrace where I found my mother on
the floor across the street from us was
a house and the guy that owned the house
rented it out and he rented every two
years that somebody knowing one time he
rented it we were outside playing when
the first kids came when the two kids
came they had a boy and a girl and the
family unloaded the truck and they got
back in the truck when they left I still
remember us playing whenever we were
playing on the street dog let's go we
broke into the house and we took [ __ ] I
took the stereo you got a badass fish
your stereo that speakers the blob punks
all [ __ ] him
blah Punk thank our speakers but you
know like the whole fish in those days
Fisher was she was the [ __ ] that was my
situation and if you had if you had the
three in one you it was still solid with
you a punk in my neighborhood you had to
have components in my neighborhood yeah
salud was this chia seeds me so much
recently because I eat a lot healthier
so are you on chia seeds and [ __ ] go
through berries and [ __ ] like that you
know I'm saying I'm trying to put the
pieces together do anyways so the
criminality with me started early
it started early you know you could
steal you could do whatever and it was
accepted
you followed me so yeah I was stealing
when I was a kid right so it was
exciting
yeah so once before my mother died I had
done a couple creepy things
nothing too creepy like bicycle [ __ ]
like that but I didn't need to do I
didn't need to do that punk ass [ __ ] but
I liked it I liked it and then after she
died it was part of the excuse to become
a criminal
so know all that [ __ ] that was the
easiest thing in the world was robbing
drug dealers
anymore that tell you the story about
robbing the church yeah yeah yeah we you
know you do all this creepy [ __ ] it's if
you continue to do it like if you
continue to in your 40s and 30s I was 12
yeah when you have a [ __ ] problem and
I stole like $14 yet you know like now
you have a boy a little boy what are you
gonna tell him you know he's gonna come
to you one day like we're already I feel
like a hypocrite in a lot of stages of
my life but I'm gonna tell the truth
eventually she's gonna find out the
truth eventually yeah she's gonna listen
to your old podcast and yeah as a
daughter when your dad passes and listen
to each of them being hooked on them
like you're addicted to a [ __ ]
Netflix TV show like you binge listen
people do that now all right take it on
podcast me binge listen
don't listen to all the way back to one
to the beginning of the library
you know it's [ __ ] crazy man podcasts
are huge for for people that work in
places where they let him wear headsets
you know I mean he let him work with I
got a post office or something man
I tell you it was a thing in Time
magazine the 50 podcasts to listen to
Time magazine glue was pretty [ __ ]
interested they re in there no no no I
didn't get to it I didn't get to it it
was more about instructional type
podcast as many as you can learn and I
think about English language from the
British formula the most popular podcast
lately just it's just amazing what the
growth has gone to you know it's in Time
magazine yeah I follow time on Twitter
yeah so whatever Twitter puts on from
the time that's what I [ __ ] breathe
so lately you've been getting into
comedy we were talking about getting
high before comedy that you're done with
that [ __ ] yeah you know um you can't do
something under pressure that you're not
that good at high you know for you I
recommend if if you want to inhale some
cannabis and do a certain activity and
it matters you know like getting on
stage matters because if you suck you're
gonna eat a lot of dicks so it does
matter and there's pressure if you're
not really that good at it hold off on
the smoke and we'd get a set master it'd
be super smooth and then when you're
really really confident then if you want
to get high you know that that's what
I'm gonna do and I got stoned my first
eight sets but you know I had mixed
results but I it's hard to put pieces
together of your comedy when they're not
even they're not even tight to begin
with thing you're trying to tie them
together and then you add a bone rip
before you can do it so I decided maybe
five sets ago to try going onstage
without smokin man it was it's I've
gotten a lot better so I'll come back
and throw some weed on on top of it once
I get good but for the meantime going
onstage just you know totally straight
is the best thing for me right now I had
to think about it when you guys were
here talking I think the first time I
got on stage and tried it well the first
time I got on stage was July 18th of 91
and then April st. Patty's Day have 92 I
hosted the show with two local comics
and then read did some blow
and it was god-awful I was like wait a
second cocaine is the chatty drug that's
the one that makes you [ __ ] talk and
talk about [ __ ] stories and get all
philosophical [ __ ] if I ate a bag of
[ __ ] on that [ __ ] yeah what am i
glowing reefer that makes you kind of
introverted yeah so I never really
[ __ ] at them and I didn't [ __ ] we
don't fight after the commies thought
and let the Comedy Store one day I smoke
some reefer and I went on stage and I'm
like a prime spot and I just died it was
lights out it was lights out well doing
a different type of scent because I had
that belly rub show we had some of those
mints and I didn't do this in I had
planned on doing at all but lately and I
even forgot like I forgot I like I just
kind of went on and on and one of the
jokes cuz I was stoned but it went it
went better than some of my other high
sets if you just go with it now here's
the deal see this this there's a lot of
different paths to this story there's a
lot of different paths to the story if
you're going up in front of an a crowd
at an eight-time and you really need
this set I said Jeff you don't [ __ ]
get high
yeah that's what I did so I'm the type
of guy if I lose at something I come
back the next day and I try it again
so at that time at the store I came back
the next day was like a Sunday which it
didn't matter and I wanted to get high
again and try and this time I killed so
here's the conclusion guys you ready for
this let's say you do a spot at the
[ __ ] fourth wall were you doing a
spot somewhere in the valley
don't man you trying one particular joke
and you're doing longer than 5 minutes
try smoking some pot because it really
doesn't matter it really doesn't matter
so you might as well come up that way
try smoking
yeah but when you do the serious rooms
for money you're getting paid and you
got a door dealing it depends and you
really trying to pull it set together
then don't get high
that's it that makes sense that makes
sense yeah
are you still gonna drink alcohol yeah
yeah you know you know I quit drinking
for a while but you know now I gotta
have a drink before I get on stage just
to loosen me up just a little bit I
don't get hammered and go on States cuz
I could be a disaster to serve just one
drink listens me up maybe a little cup
of coffee dog I've seen people get
[ __ ] up on stage and it works for some
people
and it doesn't work for some people but
I will tell you one thing you're not
going to be consistent you know just
you're smart enough like that eighteen
year old child will say you don't know
what you're talking about
yeah an adult will say you won't be
consistent there's no way it's ain't
doing anything yeah at fifty percent
yeah you can't be drunk can't be drunk
that should I have you know so what I
was listening to this
don't wasn't the store own way don't
take this the wrong way no I'm not
condoning this at all it's great three
what's wrong when you listen me you and
[ __ ] Lee take a ride where do people
ski up here Big Bear big bet and they do
comedy up there and we're getting $100
apiece and we eats driving the car we
get like a free meal we get high we get
high who gives a [ __ ] yeah we smoked a
joint before we get back in the car we
do some comedy it's a blast but you're
so goddamn seasoned and you're such a
veteran oh no you don't get a high you
got you've been doing this for 20 years
when you're first starting you gotta get
your [ __ ] together for us you got to get
that what's like me would you just do
any same thing when I go thank you - I
cannot be hard hello now when you start
out to pay attention to every detail I
got to see that caller I got to see that
[ __ ] cross I got to see everything
yeah I can not get high and that getting
high gives me fear and adds a quality of
fear to me
it doesn't let me go for things it won't
if you mount me a panic I'll tap my
breathing changes yeah by breathing it
shallow because I'm not you know it's a
different level I'm not ready my tools
aren't I'm far from being at that level
being able to get high and [ __ ] roll
around with something I'm far far far
from that level so you'll get there
calmly is the same the exact same thing
I compare college it souza what to an
art it's an art that's it doesn't
[ __ ] matter how you look at economies
a [ __ ] art and you gonna learn
something every time you go on the Met
every time you touch that microphone
you're gonna learn something it's the
same way every time you touch that Matt
you're gonna guarantee learned something
yeah somebody's gonna come to you and
say dog put your foot that way from now
on when you do that sweetly I mean oh oh
[ __ ]
look at me now and yeah I'm happy I came
to class yeah that's the best when you
don't want to do something when you're
sitting on your couch on a Tuesday night
you know like [ __ ] I got a drive up here
for [ __ ] 40 bucks and the
cheeseburger yeah and do a set god damn
it why did I agree to this [ __ ] I want
to sit home and your mom with a high
hard one and watch [ __ ] my PD blue on
[ __ ] whatever next thing then you go
to that gig and guess what there's an
agent there plus you killed plus the
headliners in the show up so you picked
up Niles at the headline it was gonna
get you know and you're like [ __ ] what
would have happen if I were to sign the
couch tonight
yeah nothing nothing I got my dick
sucked and I would have the same result
look I went to that shitty room I'm
gonna pick up a buck 40 up plus I picked
up an agent 2 plus I picked up another
gig because the MC books are [ __ ] at
night and [ __ ] San Fernando Valley I
mean that's what happened the same thing
happened to do Jitsu there's Matt you
don't really go dude you sure this days
on my [ __ ] I got to do this and then go
to jujitsu and you gotta be vitual it's
you and him or you and a purple belt he
teaches you [ __ ] he beats the [ __ ] out
of you that's the best class you've had
a long [ __ ] time yeah same thing
what's up PB I haven't read that little
breath mint hit you a little bit didn't
it
yeah I could see the [ __ ] angles the
same way sorry Febreze oh yeah take one
to go take two there you go what the
[ __ ] were you ready
um I'm free there is that you [ __ ] how
do you have me are you in love with
company right now I love it man I love
it especially when it goes good like the
let that the show and Frisco we did a
belly room show before Frisco that's the
first show I did not high and that was
the best show up the up to that point so
I thought okay cool we're gonna me and
Sam are gonna go up to Frisco and then
Sacramento I was gonna do the same thing
no weed the whole day nothing went off
stage in at Cobbs in San Francisco it
was better than the the set at the belly
room then you know we went to Sacramento
and Sacramento is special because I tell
people when they ask me about comedy
like well what's the what's the you know
like what do you like about it and I and
I tell them I love working in front of
Latin crowds I love that because then
you could just talk about your
experiences growing up as a Mexican you
know and and when I did when I opened
for you I think four different times you
bring in all the Mexicans I love work in
Mexican rooms I love it I feel really
comfortable and I also look loved
working in front of the tinfoil hat
comedy night people where everybody's
like you know on the same page
those are my two favorite book crowds I
love it I have it's so much goddamn fun
because at jujitsu well when I first did
comedy back in 2001 before tenth planet
before Templin I went up and I did open
mic nights at the Comedy Store like
maybe 10 times or something like that
well we're like mixed results but I knew
because I was already a brown belt in
jujitsu
I knew that comedy was just like jujitsu
I'm like damn you can't just go up there
and just talk [ __ ] like like you can in
the locker room at school you have to
have work ethic and right
this and go out three four nights a week
just like jiu-jitsu I knew my damn I
could do this but I'd have to have a
because I didn't have any public
speaking experience other than DJing at
a strip club and that's not real but but
like real public speaking experience I
don't have any of that so I was I knew I
was gonna ending it a lot of work so
then you know I was writing with Joe we
had all these sketches we wanted to
pitch a sketch comedy show back then and
then he ended up getting signed by
Comedy Central to do the man's show
after to Adam Carolla and Jimmy Kimmel
left him and Doug Stanhope came in and
did the comedy
did the man show and I came in it's Joe
one of Joe's writers because we were
already writing a bunch of sketches we
had like 30 sketches ready to go we were
trying to do like a Dave Chappelle type
show and I I music has always been
number one to me so my comedy was just
like something that I was that I loved
but music was always number one so I
decided at that point you know what I
don't have time to put into stand-up
comedy and it's too much work but I'll
help Joe write some sketches I go that
was cool so work in a comedy central
sucked I hated it so much it was it's a
lot that's an hour story it was terrible
so during work as I was working on the
man show I went to Brazil and did Abu
Dhabi 2003 I beat oiler Gracie who at
that point was you know the god of the
featherweight division
nobody even scored a point against him
he won three years in a row I tapped him
out as in Brazil it was a you know the
biggest upset in jiu-jitsu history at
that point and then I came back I said
[ __ ] comedy I'm gonna just gonna teach
you Jitsu you know until my music blows
up that's what I thought you know
because it was always about the music so
I walked I called John like thank you
for [ __ ] fighting for me and getting
me the job but you know I don't want to
work there I'm done with that [ __ ] I've
seen Hollywood I might I don't want
nothing to do with Hollywood even today
don't want to do that's supposed to it
was it was a horrible experience so I
opened up 10th planet but I never
stopped writing I would always write I
would always had the habit of you know
if I come up with an idea and write and
I have so many notes and I thought maybe
in a couple years I'll go back and
and try some stand up again and then was
five years I was seven years I was eight
years and then I was ten years and then
I was like fifteen years and I still
hadn't gone back but had all these ideas
so then I just decided you know last
year I thought maybe teaching jiu-jitsu
was enough public speaking experience
because I'd always try to do stand-up as
I teach you know I do seminars I never
start a seminar with a you know right
away and get into techniques I always
like [ __ ] for about five minutes and
then sometimes in stand-up comes up you
know what I mean so I was I was
wondering if that would translate was 15
years of that would I be able to get up
on stage at the Comedy Store and be
better than I was back then when I was
doing open mics and I totally sucked so
that was always in the back of my mind
so I decided to do it I told Sam I knew
Sam before 10 planet under Sam back in
the day when I met you before 10 planet
I knew you before 10 wasn't even a
thought so he you know he was doing
comedy casts and and we were all into
conspiracy theories together so he put
me up on a Tuesday night and it was the
first time in 15 [ __ ] years so I went
up there and out of although the first
10 sets that was actually the best one
because right when I got up there I had
the mic and I'm like whoa because my
students when I at school when I start
to tell a story a lot of them like coach
let's [ __ ] start it's 9:10 I'm
bombing every night in jujitsu I bought
they don't want to hear my [ __ ] they
want to do digits when I try to tell
story and I got a censor myself cuz I
don't wanna be too crazy and they're
always I'm bombing every night I don't
have a mic so when I got onstage at the
Comedy Store like the first five seconds
I'm like I have a mic this is just like
a seminar and they're drunk they don't
want to do jiu-jitsu and they want to
laugh to me I felt right away like oh
[ __ ] this is easy I got a [ __ ] mic
I'm used to doing this [ __ ] without a
mic like Fox like steroids a [ __ ] you
know a microphone is a different control
later yeah I was like I think it's a
different controller people do not
understand yeah
that's why people say you will do some
time at the club go up on stage do eight
minutes you're like I don't have a
microphone you don't need a mic
shut the [ __ ] you [ __ ] didn't either
why not shut the [ __ ] up the microphone
is the tool of tools if there's a
microphone on stage and you go up that
install the microphone for three minutes
but then you want to walk away from the
stage that's one thing that's one thing
walking away from the mic and talking to
the audience that might be funny
sometimes but to go up there dude
without a microphone you lose your
shield yeah it's really your shield it's
the power so your sword is your brain
and your arm and everything but this
microphone when you grab it it's your
shield it centers you you don't need it
you don't need it you don't need it
you're as tough as nails but it centers
your balance is you you don't Samsung
it's kind of weird not to have a
microphone and then to have a microphone
yeah so true so how'd you learn that in
jujitsu yeah I learned that muff like on
stage yeah I had a place in Craig
Colorado no Mike no Mike and it says but
when you get the paperwork I would say
this is a violent rule if [ __ ] erupts
run off to go to your room when you call
the management and then had the reason
why the room was so bad it was because
they had a mic but you were far away
from the audience yeah that's another
learning thing if you go into a room and
they're like yeah you stand there but
that 30 feet away yeah that's those
people up we'll put me in the audience
Oh get off the stage when the owner is
not watching and going to the audience
all these things are control mechanisms
that people do not know until they work
without them and then you're like oh now
I know I got a microphone hmm that's why
the guy with the microphone always wins
at a [ __ ] Club Alan oh brain deck
yeah yeah that's the comics brain-dead
yeah you should be able to destroy a
microphone right but listen to what I'm
saying to you going up without a
microphone
is completely different than going up
with a microphone and walking away from
it yeah I do that every night and I bomb
every night so it turns out then me
teaching jujitsu and trying to squeeze
in some jokes to people that don't want
to hear them it's like dragging logs up
hills it's like strength and
conditioning you know
so it actually translated I didn't know
if it was I'm like does 15 years of me
trying to tell jokes without a mic to
people that don't want to hear any
[ __ ] jokes they give me a little
laughter every now and then but they're
not into it they want to train now with
John Jacques talk
do you ever crack a joke from time to
time every now and then yeah they have
to teach it you have to have yeah some
sense of humor to break duh yeah
whatever yeah but in jujitsu you don't
have a mic they don't want to listen to
it but the cool thing is they're not
paying for you to be funny so you don't
have to be funny so you could just the
jokes are like you know that's just a
frosting on the cake you know icing on
the cake that makes it a little easier
because you don't have to be funny you
know and in seminars they they want five
minutes of your thoughts they do you
they don't you want to start out a
three-hour seminar okay grab a partner
grab his left arm put them in spiderweb
and go but you want to and sometimes you
know it's not always jokes sometimes I
do five minutes on the background of the
techniques were about to get into
there's a story then I'll tell a story
that leads into that's why we're doing
spiderweb you know what I mean like but
it's it's the public speaking practice
that really helped what's the
organization that you join if you want
to learn how to speak publicly and you
Toastmasters I've never heard of it is
it Toastmasters effort of that anything
look it up yeah it is that what I live
you know it's so weird that we they
teach you how to make toasts at like
weddings and [ __ ] so you're not so
uncomfortable is that what it is it
sounds like what it is no no no no
though I have is everybody everyone at
some point gotta give a toast you know a
wedding when I live them bold that was
the transition period before I got
arrested before I kidding that village I
was in a real transition period I was
doing well laddie I was really doing
well financially I wasn't getting rich
but from where I came from I was doing
tremendous and all I had to do was go to
this place every day and sell cars I was
doing the right Eddie so I lived with a
chick that was a redheaded chick
that big tits and a big red ass and her
mother printing store and Boulder and
she was young she if I was twenty when I
get arrested he's 287 so I was basically
23 what's no three and four I was 24
years old when I got arrested for
kidnapping so what is Toastmasters this
is um uh do you want to become a
confident public speaker so I lived with
a chick and a geeky guy right the chick
sold pot and had cats and the guy like
when you walked in the guys room to talk
to him he had a picture of a Testarossa
is war he had his goals written
everywhere
he was Anthony Robbins guy he believed
in the other guy he was into everybody
this poor bastard spent all his money
and just trying to be a better parole
that stuff like gonna well they call
those things not get rich seminars but
the other ones self-improvement like
self improve that's and he was young
guys if I was 24 he was like 23 and this
is all he talked about but he used to go
to this he used to wake up once a week
or once a week month or twice a month
and you go to this [ __ ] early and you
talk and he would say that we talked I
don't know man I don't know you're a lot
better this can you help me with this
and I would ask him what it would be and
I wasn't even doing stand-up that I
wasn't even doing stand-up that I just
crack jokes and [ __ ] around the living
room and that with these guys but he was
going to this because of his fear of
talking in public and he wanted to
improve and hear you and even leave for
example I've thrown way up in some weird
situations and he's reacted positively
like most people who I can't do that and
run out of the [ __ ] room you guys I
applaud you because I remember you going
on stage in the comedy so I brought you
up in 2001 on Sunday nights
I jump a few toriana I think even
showcase Mitzi one night I know uh Damon
Wayans was there one night on a Sunday
when I went up and I it was probably the
worst set ever you know it's the public
speaking experience that really helps
man cuz you know and the crowd the
crowds huge - cuz like I was saying in
Sacramento they were all Mexican and
they were all conspiracy theorists so it
was [ __ ] it was so much fun man it was
so much goddamn fun I loved it yeah you
know here's the [ __ ] craziest thing I
was thinking about the Spanish scene
well that first Motel away the Spanish
scene here was going to be the next big
thing and they couldn't pull it together
you know George hated this guy he hated
this guy he hated this guy but it didn't
bother me and I'll tell you why
believe it or not any I would bomb in
front of Spanish Charlotte yes hmm
in those days if you watch behind que
Loco and all those Spanish oh you dirty
No
oh yeah they didn't they don't want no
they don't want to go tinkle Rudy with
tongue pulled me on the side and tell me
if you work my rules you know working a
little cleaner show these people hold
the Mexicans l-like dirty material you
know he would always get on me Willie
Barcena would get on me a lot of Latino
comics would get on me would you change
your material not even [ __ ] close I
would go up there and work even dirtier
he stressed it Rudy stressed it and then
what might be my man on my team is yes
he had a gig out of town and Marilyn and
me that and Marilyn was a broad wasn't
even they as I got up I saw the 20 cop
cars outside
Marilyn got into it with a [ __ ] woman
the lady you said something to some guy
the guy said sometime the woman said
something they start throwing chairs it
was called the brave bull in one of
those little Spanish town yeah my mom
used to go there yeah
with her so like that it was
phenomenally Marty's the brave bull had
maybe three commie rooms oh wow
it was huge it was a Mexican [ __ ]
restaurant bar grill entertainment
wedding quinceanera I mean you'd go
there and anything was going down
there's a complex you know many times I
went down and wherever the [ __ ] it was
and I was in a different room to do
comedy like I still being there with
George Lopez and Pablo Francisco on a
Saturday oh [ __ ] I love we were in a
room that had an words like goats heads
[ __ ] bull hunter room like the I hunt
for them all down like one of those
rooms there was a rule to the macabre
head bro it was crazy that place and he
would give me work in this winters they
paid $40 a set
I'm Friday and Saturday sub as it went
down to 25 that's nothing that was
nothing but still but I didn't give a
[ __ ] I would drive down there for the
small 50 yea dude The Comedy Store
Friday and savvy in those days you did
Universal City on Fridays for 200 mmm
that's a member you just bombed you just
want to pay the mom it was a dance club
and they stopped the music coming to the
stage comedian Eddie Bravo and you ought
to be like terrible idea
Oh horrible but for 200 on a Friday
night [ __ ] I mug your mother for 200
from 10:00 to 11:00 on a Friday night
and I can still make my store and still
buy a package because now you get a
package that [ __ ] drive down to
[ __ ] the Comedy Store from universals
is tip-top Laguna your whistling Tony
Bennett [ __ ] he gets a shout out
to my man Tommy poor ol Jogi one Scully
one
bryan-michael DJ Miami Joe Lorenzo
Christopher and Geoffrey Tahoe
Tolleson I love you mother [ __ ] don't
forget your life sevens working out with
uncle Joey at the ice house July 13th
and 14th I'm at the South Pointe casino
in Las Vegas Friday
Saturday 7:30 show Your Honor there by
9:00 you're eating your wife's muffler
by 10:15 you understand me and then BOOM
we've closed out the month of July which
Salt Lake [ __ ] City wiseguys
for shows - Friday - sadly no [ __ ]
drama working on new material get my
[ __ ] together that's it
[ __ ] August we go to Kansas City we
got a [ __ ] Nashville we go to the
other place - so get ready details
coming album so yeah yeah go now
abandoned I'm going to [ __ ] now -
boom - well last week August so get
ready [ __ ] that's it that's that
now it was a fun time at collusive
casino if you came thank you thank you
for the confidence build the [ __ ]
food is great then the hotel the BEST
shower
number two the South Point legacy you
don't think you like plays oh my god
what is in the water
is it a lot of heads order the dough
space heads and the tub is brilliantly
it's not metal
it's that plastic stuff but it's curved
like like a chair that you watch TV in
okay oh oh my god and they have three
nozzles one that shoots at your balls
the other one hits your stomach and the
element hits your face so Mitch Mason
has the temperature control oh listen to
me
I had the head conditioning then I'm a
55 I had the fireplace on the portable
fireplace because that's how I roll you
understand it
I want heaven and hell I want heat and
[ __ ] cold and then I got back from
the show last night maybe 10 o'clock I
own a little something something I have
a little snacky pooh let me say it's
time I took my anabolic [ __ ]
over-the-counter sleeping pill I got
popped a couple [ __ ] anxiety tablets
about 10:30 I went into the [ __ ]
shower last night like a doctor I said I
would take a shower as I hugged a couple
people to share when I take the germs
off my neck I said let me gonna take a
shower and I go to the casino and gamble
a little bit dawg I wanted to have my
10:30 guess what I woke up with that
[ __ ] at 12:20
woke up what do you woke up passed out
man we're in the tub with my mouth open
house drowned but I didn't give a [ __ ]
jack oh I thought you're in the tub for
an hour almost two hours I slept in that
time water hitting me from all angles
the best shower in the country at Benton
second best of the South Pointe casino
the pimp room at the South Lake casino
the showers Assizes room and you got
nozzles everywhere with the chair so you
just put the nozzles on and you saw the
chair like this like Copernicus thank
you
you let that water hit you for an hour
oh no wonder you don't answer your phone
that oh no you don't hear from me at all
I get up before the morning just to take
a shower till 5:00 and I want a room
service like a doctor come on Kopernik
and I painted 252 [ __ ] smoke in the
room because it's like the Sinatra suite
so if I'm gonna pay 250 I'm smoking like
a chimney and this family lighting fires
you should I don't give a [ __ ] you
pre-painting they're fine yeah just take
the fine take the two half cuz I'm
smoking I'm not leaving the room I tell
you doing so they always they're always
charging you right and yeah I don't do a
lot of hotels cuz you can't do it you
got to be polite as kids in the hotels
but the South Point they put me up on
top the time [ __ ] room all the way in
the corner room is huge so I can smoke
in the bathroom is [ __ ] you know the
bat like that I could smoke in the shot
you how many times I've gone to shower
with a joint and turn the shower and I
said Kelly corner
[ __ ] smoker join them bang one out
I'm on my feet when you come on your
feet you sit there and watch it it's on
your fungi toe you don't give a [ __ ]
about when you come like the sink is
kind of clogged and it goes up to your
ankles and you come and then you have
come on your ankles because it's good
for your skin rubbing into your feet
your feet get slippery any of these
problems just and you don't jerk off in
the shower
no oh there's your problem that's your
problem that's what men jerk off you lay
back and your Brangwyn out like a
fountain something lays on your stomach
some of the lays on your thighs you
scratch it
the only thing will stick them remember
the stick them spray and they had in the
eighties the Pittsburgh Steelers yeah
it's like stick them anything
sticks to you like had he brought what's
amazing the [ __ ] journey we boasting
ourselves do you know it really isn't I
still want to sit with you in Houston's
Louise Ciccone Easton's all the [ __ ]
time and we do that time the videos
there's that y'all again we is tenth
planet cush yes tenth planet crush
that's right planet we're still on
YouTube you can still watch I still wish
we used to go to you Evan
UFC predictions your sea predictions
10th planet cush we did about like 20 we
would have meet before you get on the
plane yeah like we would see you would
stop and meet me on the way to the plane
yeah me you Dan Hardy did one yeah yeah
a couple of us did like some great the
[ __ ] that Mexican food I talked to
those guys for years after they closed I
kept in touch with one of the cooks hell
on the phone he would call me from time
to time yeah that's how much we like
them and they like me remember because
he was family I would call him up to see
if he was working we did most of them at
Houston's abuses at Houston's and
generally you'd make like about five
predictions and you would get you know
sometimes three rides sometimes two it
didn't matter you never killed it all
except the one time we decided to do it
at your house and then I ended up
videotaping all your cats and I made
like all the cats were around
videotaping them you're giving me each
story on each cat and you know you know
their personalities and the background
and all that [ __ ] and for some reason
with all those cats there was like
something in the air man when you were
ready to go and I turned on the camera
and you went it was a ten planet cush
I think episode 20 it's the one with all
the cats that one there was some
electricity in the air man you were on
fire it was one take we said go and you
nailed every fight every fight you had
right and I remember driving home I
couldn't wait to edit it because I knew
there was something super special about
I didn't know you're obviously I didn't
know you were gonna nail every fight but
that one just with all the cats and I
don't know maybe maybe it's true maybe
you know how they say that a cats purr
or generates positive energy that you
could pick up you know what I mean
that's what you know crazy cat lady say
I felt something all those cats were all
around and and they are you could see
their personalities and then you picked
up Fidel you picked them up and we start
the the previews or Direction can love
the cameras
oh man that's that's one of the greatest
yo-yo game you had a camera the dough
would [ __ ] get up and walk in front
what's up [ __ ] I'm here to see
I'd love to see that actually like he'd
the fast-forward to that the part where
you give the predictions cuz you were on
[ __ ] fire with you it was so funny
and it was the only one most of them
when I was filling them you would say
like two or three things that were funny
and I'm I'm videotaping you could hear
me laugh this one I was laughing the
whole way through I couldn't stop
laugh and you were just it was like what
it was like when you went up in Columbus
that one time when you open for Joe and
he was filming that monkeys in space
thing when you went up I'll never forget
ever watching from the side stage you
were sweating and spitting and everybody
was dying you were crushing like it was
just gold it was like fires like you
just you just had magic that night it
was crazy man I'll never forget that
night although she is opening up for Joe
yeah we'll [ __ ] magical it is crazy
like crazy me and Joe are always on the
side rondell or the education was
mind-boggling Joe doesn't know that I
took his book like John Jacques gave you
his black belt Joe gave me his black
belt and I just tweaked a couple
elements that now we both live by we
both do like I used to tell him more for
years Joe we I leave early on Sunday
[ __ ] that
I'm now getting up to one man I would
[ __ ] leave the night before I'm
stranded
I would [ __ ] with his emotions his [ __ ]
so he [ __ ] listen doll you got kids
you got to be back on the first flight
they don't want
and we don't yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] get
up at a nanny breakfast and the flights
delayed
my seminar zones generally on Saturday
and right when I'm done with that
afternoon seminar I'm way to the airport
five o'clock at home Saturday night it's
uh I don't have time for vacation it's
really weird how that was that was my
apprenticeship that's the true story
that that's you know when I write my
book on comedy it was ten years
oh bleep the joke that was crazy I sawed
a combo I saw from the beginning and
then like every now and then you know
they'd switch it up either Duncan would
be that the one who opened and then you
and then Joe or Ari and I John Efron
even but uh man those are the days man
and what about well it was me and Ari
and Duncan yeah there was shows what was
me Ari
Duncan red band you tape in the [ __ ]
audience yeah and Joe you know we go
either [ __ ] 2:00 in the morning and
Joe would pick up this I mean it was
[ __ ] crazy
it was just pure I'm not renting a van
it lost I was single as [ __ ] back then
so anytime Joe went on the road
he just dragged me along you know and I
went I went on there I wasn't even a
comedian back then I was just living the
life of a comedian but not getting
onstage I didn't get out watching I was
watching you were watching yeah and
that's time served
yeah in my world likely watching me
going out bah-bah-ba-wa that's time
served
yeah that's why transition that's
apprenticeship it's time served you
watched it you see what I think joe said
probably 2000 times just over over I
knew is set in siding out you know I
wouldn't even listen to his jokes in
where I would be fascinated by listen
paying attention to the people that
there was always two or three people
maybe one that wasn't laughing at all
everyone's dying Joe's destroying and
and I always find the one dude who's not
laughing it on he's usually with this
wife and he's just sitting like this
just he is not happy about his wife
another guy making his wife laugh
may Wow look at that guy he's not
laughing it [ __ ] that guy I was
fascinated with [ __ ] like that
there's nothing worse cuz you see it
right away you see it right away it
sticks out like a thumb
when a woman is a fan of your comedy and
her husband isn't a fan of anything he's
just a pukey guy that's a hater
yeah and in fact she's paying for the
tickets yes she dragged him out he
dragged him out he didn't want and she's
laughing at every [ __ ] that isn't any
jokes she's just like I can't wait to
laugh and the guy is furious yes and I
saw it over the years to the worst one I
ever saw was Ontario Ontario was the
worst one I ever saw when I went up
first and a guy was heckling and I said
sometimes I think I got really pissed
then when showing up he started heckling
Joe right off the [ __ ] bat like
something about a wig or something I'll
never forget that this is mm this is the
highly [ __ ] fear factor yeah and this
guy's heckling Joe and there was a big
bouncer do you remember that guy in
Ontario I don't mean he was a steroid
freak I saw him he is late and he was
skinning or what happened man I had a
heart attack no [ __ ]
you were drinking that [ __ ] bro he was
yo this poor guy oh he got the guy and
threw him out but something happened
outside there was an ugly altercation
the cops came to chick finally got out I
went outside and she came back and
started yelling something happened with
the guy they [ __ ] them up before the
cops got there or something it was not
way no but and then there was the time
when I shout my special it's Chicago the
guy in the front row that kept moving
around this [ __ ] Eddie for two minutes
I'm saying jokes and I'm trying to
figure out how I'm gonna kick this guy
in the face without nobody singing I'm
taking just in my mind either I could
just kick him and he would just drop and
I can just keep going and nobody would
say another yeah I've seen that enough
where like now when I'm onstage if
there's a
you know a girl sitting with a guy I'll
do my best to ignore that table I don't
even want I don't want to make anybody
uncomfortable at all you know I just
stare at nothing you know if you don't
talk to the audience you guys are well
trained in that aspect like that's why I
know you've both studied the cavity
because you don't talk to the audience
like asking where they're from and well
yeah that's a habit you pick up in New
York yeah way to get [ __ ] started though
you know no it's good
no it's not I do that in in seminars you
know sometimes I'll start a seminar like
where you you know I'll do a little of
that but I've worked the crowd right I
haven't done it yet in in real time no
having real time is different [ __ ]
pain yeah because if they don't say them
tea and then [ __ ] silence your
heart stops and missing beat like you
and if you don't got anything funny to
say off it Daniel you're risking it
going you ask them you're trying to ask
us some [ __ ] you can't even think of any
fine [ __ ] leaving my leg up a tenth
planet you I'm saying this they put my
leg up it's landed saying take my leg
I'm gonna block your funk in the end you
like I think it's uh jujitsu and
stand-up correlate so much it's and I
didn't know - I joined jujitsu because
right away I improved my colleague game
improved right away I saw a bunch of
gaps in my hole a bunch of holes in my
game as soon as I was like six seven
months into jujitsu I had so many holes
in my personal life but I couldn't
imagine I'm really I'm having my comedy
game so I strive to fill those [ __ ]
holes as much as I could
a my [ __ ] writing but I think I'm
starting to over right dog why I'm like
cuz I'm not a writer I'm the type of
dude that goes out there with three
sentences and just gets the party
started with anything I'm trying to be
someone that and that's what happened
with boiler know you learn a lot from
every time you shoot a special I'm not
gonna shooting specials I'm not a good
special shooter
see these I'm not bad at specials an
ungulate I choke its pressure
now there's it's uh it's no joke there's
nothing's guarantee have none to lose on
this Netflix thing maybe you're just
being hard maybe it's amazing and you
just you're just hard on yourself maybe
when you look back it's amazing it's not
amazing they're gonna make it look good
I'll make it sound good but it's not
gonna be [ __ ] what I really would
could do the damage I can know which you
know I listen you living your life
brother 27 years you still live in
Atlanta that's the beauty of this thing
what's it like the cameras or what easy
what do you think really affected you it
was me the last two weeks going into
that last two weeks I [ __ ] up my mind
a little bit I did some my [ __ ] and done
I want to talk dark place I said I going
to a better place
purposely just to see where the but it
was too late to do that I should have
done that three or four weeks earlier I
decided to do that with a week left to
go which wasn't good to do there was a
lot of mistakes I made what I did was
was go to places where I wasn't gonna be
like where those jokes I say in front of
a podcast guy will laugh because they
know me from the podcast or from Joe's
podcast but I went to places that
wouldn't know me I wouldn't put myself
on the schedule do you follow me yeah so
I saw what jokes the general public
wasn't laugh of it
because I wanted to see what would
appeal on Netflix hmm because we're
definitely she's not doing this show for
these people you're doing a show for
viewers but that's what I thought hmm
now you've learned that you just got it
that's all [ __ ] that's oh let me
catch up to what that's what went on yes
be funny yeah that's all I have a beat
was be funny
so last night I thought how and I still
have another hour to go I went up to my
room I know what the [ __ ] was that two
weeks ago I couldn't even come up with
27 minutes could even do 30 didn't even
have the confidence to do [ __ ] 30
minutes how long ago two weeks ago huh
June 4th June 16th and there was
tremendous last night tremendous hmm
I was loose I had a great time up on
stage so you live in your learning
people he's not [ __ ] perfect
at least you're strong enough to say the
truth
and not dismiss everything that that
that helps calmly a lot is being honest
to yourself that helps in every aspect
yeah that just calmly we need you to
whether you're a plumber whether you're
an author whether you're writer and
helps with every [ __ ] the degree that
you have to look at yourself every six
months and go what the [ __ ] am I doing
wrong you know but sometimes you
overanalyze that and it kills what
you're doing why ruin why you dismissing
what got you to the game what got you to
the dance what's how expression why
change it you know yeah why change what
got you to the dance
this we got you to this now you want to
be smart and that's a mistake i boy to
four years this time I didn't avoid it
hmm well we get smart Eddie is what we
fail stay stupid but we're stupid we do
great there's only these two yeah it's a
scoop have no problem with that
no I'm a master in that me neither
that's when we do our best work when we
stay stupid but we get smart and try to
be geniuses let me show you I'm coming
here that's when we [ __ ] go what the
[ __ ] glad you do then you're acting like
Johnny white my guy yeah come on Johnny
white brown might as well go to Disney
and stop people have that opposed to him
saying you can't go in the point where
the [ __ ] another but what do you give
a [ __ ]
thought when that guy came up to me and
said that time and he followed me and I
didn't go to my room I was pissed
how is it fair yeah you look pissed I
didn't know what was going on that was
already through security I would you
like looking back on what what this does
not look good on you failed the cop test
you failed the cop test now you're here
breaking my [ __ ] balls and that's
what basically those guys are they
failed the test the first time they
ended up push-ups then give a roast beef
sandwich or something didn't go right
they didn't pass the mental young-sam
disney don't do a mental who the [ __ ]
knows I don't [ __ ] know but for them
to act that way that's the people that
usually act that way are the people that
got booted from something and now you
know they couldn't be a cop for some
reason I'm Spanish
mall cop yeah mall cop I can't deal with
that [ __ ] this is what you got a weapon
loan then what do you give a [ __ ] if you
ain't got a weapon we play sheriff for
[Music]
if you've got a gun or machine gun I can
see you stopping me but if you got a
weapon why you playing [ __ ] cop for
you get shot like the rest of us they
put you out here to [ __ ] play a cop
with no good and you're actually
believing that [ __ ] people don't listen
to you about a [ __ ] gun the [ __ ] is
wrong with people the [ __ ] is wrong with
people I need Bravo
what are you doing stand up again Eddie
right now Live Nation with Candace from
she's Candace is a the one who put
together the San Francisco and
Sacramento gigs she's my sister-in-law
she's to work for Live Nation and she
still kind of works for him and she
she's the one who presented the idea to
the guy at the top and he said well if
they sell out San Francisco and
Sacramento we'll put them on we'll get
some more dates for him and San
Francisco was it would never having a
comedy festival that weekend it was the
worst weekend ever
and we still got 350 people in there and
is 400 yeah we got 350 and then
Sacramento we're 10 short of selling it
out Sacramento boat shows oh just one
shot we just did one show we did want to
show each and Live Nation's there were I
guess they were satisfied because
they're gonna keep it going we're gonna
go to Philly Austin I don't know what
we're trying to figure out there you do
ten for comedy oh yeah 10 for at comedy
no well it's 10 for copy do you do
regular Tommy you just do comedy about
aliens
[ __ ] it's it's just my regular set but
my regular set is a little it's you know
somewhere in between conspiracies and
you know stories of me growing up it's
it's not all it's it's I'm not preaching
it's actually I'm making more fun of
more fun of Tim flow hack conspiracy
theories and actually pushing it but you
know I just I didn't want to be preachy
and you know and
I just want to be you know just tell
funny stories and it's hard it's hard
making conspiracy theories funny but I
like doing comedy in front of a room
where they're at least down with the
tower seven conspiracy you know we
thought we call the show's tower seven
and over you gotta at least be down
because if you're way on the other side
you ain't gonna laugh today you ain't
gonna like me you might as well get that
refund right now so that's the whole
point of it it's just basically putting
together a show where we're all the same
page you know I you know I don't care
about making people you know the Lib
tardes laugh I don't care about them at
all they can they can watch Jimmy
Gaffigan or something you know what I
mean he's awesome I love him too but you
know that's you know that's generally
not my crowd I get you as I said so we
did tinfoil hat comedy night just twitch
when I was listening to you I was just
thinking about what material I would do
Tim fun losing tinfoil hat tinfoil hat
I'll be like if I do a guest spot like I
would talk about I would have to beat
something with the candidates
most comedians have without even knowing
to have some conspiracy theory stuff in
their comedy like you'd listen to Katt
Williams has a lot of conspiracy theory
stuff in there you know what I mean but
it's basically
a lot of comedy is making fun of the
official stories like like Dave
Chappelle for instance he talked about
he says they said AIDS comes from
monkeys that's what they said they want
us to believe that cuz you know how hard
it is the [ __ ] of monkey you know what I
mean that's Dave Chappelle that's
conspiracy theory stuff so it's like
that you know I mean it's not like
preachy it's just we're kind of just
making fun of it you know what I mean
I'm not trying to get killed that's the
bottom line I'm not gonna go out there
and try to be [ __ ] Che Guevara or
[ __ ] Alex Jones I don't want to be
that guy I'm not trying to be that guy
if you ask me about conspiracy theories
all I'll tell you the truth you know how
to mean I don't think we went to the
moon you know I mean I'll tell you my
opinions but I don't want to be this
[ __ ] leader of conspiracy theories I
like talking about them they're
fascinating but I'm not trying to get
killed
I don't need to get hung on some door
with a scarf you know to me I'm not
trying to do that not trying to expose
it I'm not trying to poach it full of
existing yeah and you know what I will
get serious about some conspiracy
theories I do it on podcast all the time
but I don't have to I'm not trying I
don't have a mission to put anybody in
jail or to get anybody busted or
anything like that I don't want to get
suicided I'm not trying to do any of
that so you know you can call me a
Schiller whatever who the [ __ ] I mean I
just a few questions I don't know if you
know this where I come from in Jersey
it's where they see the most Washington
views in the country where you know that
right where northern New Jersey is where
they see the most Martian landings I've
had people on the show before and I
broke it down for them yeah where I come
from Hudson County Park YouTube Martians
1976 where I come from that Park where
we used to do all we used to mug the
pedophiles do [ __ ] we were kids we were
kids they closed that park off for a
couple days
because there was a rocket ship that
landed on that [ __ ] thing like that
like like the same thing I've ever
landed on the moon with the little four
legs and then landed and Hudson County
Park bro I grew up and the [ __ ] all
the government agencies came they roped
it off and they took [ __ ] samples
from the soil and the people live in
those buildings like six of us eight
witnesses got hit by cars and died a
heart attack city [ __ ] which I said
hundun I can't County Park Martians
Martha and one guy or two people we're
talking about the lights how they saw
the lights and the thing landed Hudson
County Park and that four little things
when astronaut suits came up and they
took samples of dirt and [ __ ] this is
classic [ __ ]
in fact I'm one of the Sopranos they
stayed they spoke about when they will
have an argument then I said then two
months ago you were saying that you saw
a rocket ship in Tenafly all that area
is hotbeds for [ __ ] Marshall landings
is [ __ ] like that looking pay go UFOs
leave the name of the video Joey Diaz
your faux sightings Knutson County Park
oh my god then it is right they have
done what the [ __ ] you think give the
Emily problem that's so long is there
any clips and they was talking about on
the podcast
right there UFO's North Bergen New
Jersey tell a history channel [ __ ]
dog this is no joke how you [ __ ] with
ug money you think I would [ __ ] this
is also a place where there have been
persistent claims of alien and UFO
sightings Georgia Barsky owned a
Manhattan liquor store and drove the
same route back to his home in North
Bergen New Jersey every night for
decades
at 3:00 a.m. on the morning of January
12 1975 as he was driving through the
local park his radio reception suddenly
became distorted meaning subsequent
events to UFO investigator Budd Hopkins
who recorded his story with a portable
tape recorder yeah it's time it came to
be I would say maybe Pete Hodge
[Music]
he describes small figures who got out
he said they look like kids as snow
suits and they were each one carrying a
kind of a squarish receptacle and a long
spoon like shovel they dug soil samples
extremely quickly spooning up the dirt
put it in the little spatulas and got
back in the craft he said they moved
incredibly fast like kids coming down
fires what do you think and the thing
took a drop he was absolutely new if you
want we don't want to know what I think
see even after George oh you want to
hear crazy [ __ ] oh but he had encounter
that's the [ __ ] you know many grams
of coke I bought in that building that's
why it's Urkel they called the grinder
it's a circle building I you know I used
to be a big UFO guy I was all you know
about it right you know you uh you all
the reports and the sightings and then
it looked like the government was trying
to cover it up with Project Blue Book
you're like look it's real because look
the government's trying to cover it up
but when you look into it up from the
dawn of time all dictators and emperors
and tyrants they all they all have the
same gold or same ultimate dream
one-world government they all wanted it
and it was they all try to figure out
how the [ __ ] can they get everybody to
be under one [ __ ] emperor and they
knew way back
and in Babylon times that the best way
the quickest way would be if there was
some sort of invasion from the sky if
there was some sort of invasion then
everybody would just jump in and agree
to a one-world government they wouldn't
have to do all this propaganda and
mindfuck you know mindfuck routines so
but they could never do it you know how
are you gonna get everyone to believe
that there's the fake alien invasion
that was just something that they it was
it's been written it's like a Jesuit
Order plan but there's no way you kind
of gonna do that are you gonna fake an
alien invasion
so I'm if you want to get crazy and it's
it the crazy people believe that it's
always been the grand plan and that's
what we've been working to step-by-step
they believe that like Roswell and all
those Martian movies in the 50s were all
designed to to convince people that the
aliens could convince people did it that
it's possible that we could be attacked
by aliens and that would push the
one-world government they know that's
the ultimate goal so you know still the
technology back in the 50s and 60s it
looks like [ __ ] they look at those
Martian movies like no one's gonna
believe that [ __ ]
so the conspiracy theory is the
government decided let's pretend like
we're hiding it let's stage some [ __ ]
like like crash some [ __ ] just tell
people like you know spread the rumors
that themselves that it was an alien
aircraft and post a bunch of [ __ ] like
Roswell's was was faked it was some
government saya that [ __ ] they made you
think they wanted you to think that they
were covering it up so this is that this
is the crazy conspiracy theory so year
after year that was the plan the plan
was we we have to get everyone to
believe somehow that it's possible that
we can get attacked by aliens from space
so that's where all the movies came from
Star Wars
everything the moon missions Disneyland
all that [ __ ] to get us to believe that
that to prepare us for the fake alien
invasion that will direct us right into
a new world order and they get the
presidents to say that in front of the
UN I want to play something real quick
it's gonna take one cell this is
Ragan this is Ronald Reagan and this is
they all say this Clinton Obama even
Trump said it they have a speech that
they're supposed to say and this is it
right here this is the speech there's
it's gonna be 15 seconds look at this
this is Ronald Reagan at the UN all
right to make us recognize this common
bound I occasionally think how quickly
our differences worldwide would vanish
if we were facing an alien threat from
outside this world see so he Ronald
Reagan said it all these presidents are
saying go ahead and set it on on the
Jimmy Kimmel show the exact same thing
he says the same thing so that's the
conspiracy theory it's called Project
Blue Beam Project Blue Beam is the plan
and Bill Cooper the guy who wrote a
behold the pale horses he's a US Naval
Intelligence whistleblower and he said
this is the plan he's been saying this
is nice they're gonna put Holograms in
the sky and make you believe that we're
being attacked by aliens right now you
can get on YouTube and you can punch in
City floating in the sky in China and
you could watch it and there's a city
floating in the sky
no one believes it's real they're like
this is some kind of [ __ ] projection
what the [ __ ] is going on you could
there's all sorts of [ __ ] on YouTube
what dudes are filming crazy [ __ ] in the
sky like weird ass [ __ ] [ __ ] and of
course no one believes it people are
like that's [ __ ] that it how can that
be real that's a hologram so what
they're doing is they're getting it into
our consciousness they're getting us
like it's been the plan for thousands of
years and now we have the technology to
actually do it fake some alien [ __ ]
scare people just like Ronald Reagan
said II you're and I'm saying Trump even
said it he said the exact same speech
word-for-word whether what the [ __ ] why
are they trying to drill this now we're
ready everyone believes that there's
gonna be a fake alien or that there's
gonna be a well the conspiracy theorists
think that this is going to be a there's
a fake alien invasion coming to push us
to a one-world order
that's what Project Blue Beam look look
that up those are the apocalypse another
they just want to scare the [ __ ] out of
us global warming they're just they're
trying to scare and it scares with the
environment
scare us from space scare us from
terrorism scare us with nuclear bombs
these are all just scare tactics they
scare us so that we give up more money
to fund to stop this
that's what global warming is about they
want that carbon tax that's that [ __ ]
global carbon tax all that money all
those politicians are gonna be able to
just steal they're gonna be that's the
there I go we're we're we're blowing up
the world you got to turn off your car
you know it's it's scare tactics
overpopulation apparently they've been
trying to skip they they're been trying
to scare us with overpopulation since
the seventies they said by the year 2000
you know we're gonna there's there's not
gonna be any oil and and we're gonna by
the year 2000 people gonna be standing
on top of each other's [ __ ] heads
they were trying to they're writing
books about this trying to scare us
meanwhile you could fit today's entire
population with a house making an
everyone in the in the world could have
their own house in Texas how the [ __ ]
are we overpopulated that's [ __ ] if
that's true and they say the same thing
about Alaska you could fit the entire
world's population in Alaska they can
all have their own house you know how it
seems unbelievable that wait a minute
aren't we overpopulated if that's true
and I would talked about it on Joe
Rogan's podcast it seems like it's true
cuz he would be all over it if it wasn't
just overpopulation is it's just a big
scare
oh that's just that's just the crazy
talk that's it
always a pleasure having a tea Bravo you
let us know when you're doing your next
show on the road whatever EBI is coming
up though that's what is that can i plug
that yeah EBI sixteen next Sunday in San
Diego at the San Diego Performing Arts
Center
EBI sixteen we're gonna have a 16 woman
bantamweight tournament featuring BIA
Basilio BIA mesquita Luana al goos ear
these are all IBJJF world champions the
two beers mesquite and Basilio
there are probably the best girls in the
world right now what do they weigh oh
that you have to be 135 same day well
they watch this online you can watch it
on UFC fight pass or you can get tickets
for the show if you're anywhere in
Southern California go to inch-by-inch
dot TV and the main event is combat
jujitsu it's gonna be Ritchie boogie man
Martinez versus Bobby Emmons for the EBI
cjj welterweight belt
Ritchie's the belt the belt holder right
now he's the champion Bobby's coming in
there it's it's a rematch Ritchie beat
him the first time and Bobby's coming
back he's gonna try to redeem himself
and also PJ Barch he's one of the
fastest-rising tenth planet soldiers out
there he's gonna fight combat jiu-jitsu
against Nikki rolls so we have a 16
woman sub only tournament Plus to combat
jujitsu bouts one for that welterweight
belt
wait [ __ ] around oh yeah you know I
don't play [ __ ] around
like I said July 7th the Icehouse the
13th and 14th South Pointe casino that's
it and that's that you bad [ __ ]
again happy belated Father's Day thank
you if it came out for the kulusuk
casino and thank you for listening for
the church or what's happening now with
my man Hanny Bravo and the [ __ ]
[ __ ] over there any insane
mutts tonight the Brett's great got him
anyway number one on it my heart I've
been with them since day one they've
been with me since day one why because
there's supplements work from the Alpha
brain which they'll give you hundred
percent back money-back guarantee and I
don't want the product to my [ __ ]
favorite shrimp deck I live on that [ __ ]
i snort that [ __ ] I love shrimp export
and the immune I fly a lot you don't see
me with no mass with a Japanese [ __ ]
look on my face why because I do shrooms
deca meeting [ __ ] and I eat ask
the flu ain't gonna get me and I'm
saying so that's the way we do it gonna
calm right now press in church BAM
and get 10% off delivered straight the
house number two when it comes to G's
mats shin guards any of that stuff a
jump rope a kettlebell holder fuji
sports car delaware they know my
favorite gear in the world fuji sports
rash guard fuji I love everything to do
with Fuji they've been around since
Jesus left Chicago quality quality
whether it's a new Sekou point to all ye
- the [ __ ] just all-purpose - the
beautiful competition gear that they
have so the super-ego which is my
[ __ ] favorite lightweight durable
[ __ ] tough for the shoe leather you
understand me go to Fuji Sports calm
right now impress in church BAM
CH you are CH and get 10% off delivered
to your [ __ ] house I want to
thank the master Eddie Bravo 10th planet
JJ calm 10th for conspiracy
[ __ ] wizard I want to thank the
Christ killer over there and I want to
thank you guys for listening stay black
and we'll see you Thursday what's up no
I have another show at the Sycamore
tavern all sure 26 at 8:30 coming if you
are in town and wanted to come you're
more than welcome awesome thank you um
and yeah let's Emile what's the 26 it
was a Tuesday Tuesday all right there
you have it you have the whole [ __ ]
schedule I love you [ __ ] one
more time for Fuji Sports calm and one
more time finally stay black see you
Wednesday morning